it's an honor to be here and really
excited to be talking about Cordo and
python together
uh so as uh mentioned my name is Tom
mock I work at posit which we recently
rebranded our name from our studio
deposit and I'm actually a product
manager and customer enablement lead uh
there at posit
just in case you aren't familiar with
deposit the company I do have this slide
for kind of future use but our studio
PBC recently rebranded deposit PPC kind
of to Encompass this idea that we're
doing more than just R and more than
just our studio so we actually been
contributing both financially and Via
open source to a lot of python and R
over the past few years
just including that as we kind of get
started
but really I'm here to talk about quarto
and that's kind of part of our open
source Mission so what is quarto quarto
is an open source scientific and
Technical publishing system that builds
on standard markdown with features that
are essential for scientific
communication
these computations could be in many
languages things like obviously python
is what we're thinking about today but
also things like R and Julia and even
JavaScript or observable JavaScript
we're worried about markdown in this
case and scientific markdown we use
pandok flavored markdown with a lot of
enhancements to make it easier to put
together documents scientific Computing
and overall structure your documents in
a cohesive way
and that output doesn't have to just be
a document the slide deck you're seeing
today was actually made with quarto and
this is actually reveal.js presentation
made with Cordo that includes both
computation markdown and the final
output I'm showing today but you can
also make websites books blogs or
Journal articles in addition to basic
documents
so overall this is the idea of literate
programming combining computation
markdown output altogether and there's
lots of different kind of History here
things like org mode weave our markdown
I publish Jupiter book Jupiter notebooks
it's a lot of things going on and I'll
talk a little bit about how Cordo kind
of combines some of the ideas and builds
upon some of the ideas
the origins of Cordo actually started
over a decade ago
um Cordo is an open source project
sponsored by positpvc again formerly
known as our studio PBC kind of keep
hitting on that idea
and we have over 10 years of experience
building our markdown this is a system
that's relatively similar to Cordo but
one that was really our specific it used
in our package it relied on r as a
language but overall this convinced us
that the core ideas were sound because
of how popular it became and because of
how many people built around it and
built entire ecosystems around it
however as you can imagine the number of
languages and runtimes used for
scientific discourse and scientific
Computing is very Broad and no one
language are python SQL JavaScript Julia
rust no one language covers it all so we
wanted to kind of redesign our markdown
to not be as dependent upon R allow R to
be used but also allow other languages
like Python and Julia to be used
natively within it
so quarto is this ground up reimagining
of our markdown that is fundamentally
multi-language and multi-engine what I
mean by that is like of course you can
natively execute R but you can also
natively execute python natively execute
Julia use Jupiter notebooks use quarto
markdown documents there's lots of
different ways you can use it as opposed
to having to work only through this R
markdown workflow
ultimately Cordo gets inspiration from
both our markdown and Jupiter notebooks
and provides both a plain text option
similar to how our markdown was written
or the native use of Jupiter notebooks
and Jupiter kernels if you want to stay
within kind of that workflow and I'll
talk again quite a bit more about both
of those as we move along
so goal number one for quarto in terms
of like building up this picture is that
it's a computational document it's a
document that includes the source code
for the production of that document so
it's self-documenting
Porto includes a notebook style so
literal Jupiter notebook IPython
notebook as well as a plain text flavor
where you see the pure markdown as
opposed to kind of the Json structure
that makes up a jupyter notebook
it allows for programmatic automation
reproducibility so you can generate many
reports from a single report and with
the source code you can recreate or
reproduce that analysis in the future
and this is a big part about why open
source is so valuable is kind of solving
bits and pieces of the reproducibility
crisis
a second goal of Cordo is this idea of
enhanced or uh scientific markdown
so if you think about some of the
documents you've written or articles
you've written over time you probably
started somewhere with something like
Google Docs or word really easy to get
started but as your document complexity
increases it actually gets really hard
to structure your document consistently
and you start putting an image in and it
shifts things off the page it's hard
so next you move on to something like
latex or latex and it's harder to get
started but really powerful across the
kind of the picture
but again it's it's really hard to get
started and it's relatively limited to
creating things like PDF or maybe Beamer
slides or things like that
with markdown you get some of the
benefits of really easy to get started
plain text formats but then you start
running to this issue of this
unsupported syntax or difficulties so
Cordo provides more syntax and makes
more syntax available to make it easier
to create both simple and complex
documents over time and I'll show off
some of that as we move forward
the last goal of Cordo is truly building
on the idea of single Source publishing
of course you can take a document
render it out generate one kind of
Journal article and that's your workflow
you're just generating this specific
type of Journal article that's possible
with quarto but quarto can also generate
slides in HTML or in latex it can
generate HTML and docx and PDF documents
entire websites blogs and books all from
the same source code without having to
modify and add a new CSS and new HTML
and new latex just to get it working so
really building this idea of real single
Source publishing
to kind of hit on this idea of like
scientific Computing scientific markdown
reproducibility computational documents
I have a simple example here of source
code for a quarto markdown document on
the left and the output of that document
on the right
so you can see on the right that we have
a nice looking little image and a little
plain article it's got some different
formatting and on the left we have the
structure of a basic quarter document
so we have a yaml header this is the
front matter or metadata that allows us
to set up the document and control how
it's uh kind of what format we're going
to what language we're using
we have markdown an enhanced markdown
allowing us to do things like cross
references links or structuring of the
document
and then we have source code or python
code chunks that allow us to create
Graphics or run analyzes or create
tables or anything else we can do with
python or other languages and embed that
into the document on the Fly
and this is really powerful for all of
the kind of goals that we have moving
forward
now this simple example is great but
what if I don't want to build for HTML
so quarter can be rendered to dozens of
output formats with quarto via pandok so
it's building around pandok as a
conversion tool so you can take the
exact same source code exact same
document and render to HTML or PDF or
docx or ePub or PowerPoint or reveal.js
slides like the ones I'm using today
so there's a lot of power here for many
formats not just a single one where if
you have to convert to one another one
it's very hard and complex
what this really means we look at the
big picture is that similar to our
markdown but now enhanced with quarto
and available for all languages we have
all sorts of things you can create basic
documents presentations Advanced layouts
entire books cross references page HTML
working on things like even dashboards
websites and blogs so the future is
bright in in terms of what you can do
now and what you can do in the future
with Cordo so I'm really excited about
all the different things you can build
with it
so let's go back to that start and say
like well what is chordo then so
restating myself Cordo is an open source
scientific and Technical publishing
system built on pandok pandok's allowing
you to do all this conversion but quarto
is providing a lot of structure and
Power on top of pandok
so Cordo is really a language agnostic
command line interface or a CLI
if I do something like install quarto
and then call quarto dash dash help for
my terminal I'd get something like this
and say hey you're on version
1.2.269 and you have a number of
commands and I've abbreviated those
commands for this slide here
so number one you can render you can
take an input file and render it out to
a different type of output so again
maybe I start with HTML but then I have
to do a journal article so I want to
convert it to PDF it could be as simple
as quarter render to PDF
I can also record a preview which allows
me to not only render the document but
also maintain a live window that as I
save and make changes it actually
updates in real time and re-renders the
document and shows me what the final
output looks like
and then lastly Cordo is a publishing
system so I can work on things locally
but I can also publish to GitHub Pages
or to netlify or even professional tools
like posit connect behind a firewall
within your Enterprise or to quarto pubs
which is a free website we maintain for
publishing
so a lot of different powerful things
you can do with Cordo but these three
core ideas of rendering previewing and
publish are the core structure of what
quarto allows for
if we look at a basic workflow it might
look something like this
quarter render a python.quarter markdown
document and then we can say which
version we want to render it out to so
PDF or HTML but we can also take
existing Jupiter notebooks as is and
also render them out we can optionally
use the stored computation so someone
hands off a jupyter notebook that
already has computation stored inside of
its Json structure or we can re-execute
it linearly from top to bottom if we
want to make sure that things were done
in the same order and not out of order
and preview is almost identical where
you can quarter preview both quarter
markdown documents and Jupiter notebooks
but now you're previewing that live
content and you can save and make
changes and make sure that the final
output looks exactly like you want it to
look like
so very very exciting in terms of you
can use the chordal markdown structure
or a Jupiter notebook you get to choose
when we talk about Jupiter I'm really
talking here about both Jupiter
notebooks and Jupiter kernels so things
like IPython and the IPython kernel for
our markdown we really needed to have R
and use Knitter in our markdown as the
engine and the framework but with quarto
and specifically for python we can
natively execute python with Jupiter
kernels such as IPython
the indicated or default python kernel
on your system is bound automatically
when Porto finds a python executable
cell chunk so you can either use the
defaults or you can set a specific
kernel in the yaml header so I can say
hey I have a Jupiter kernel I've named
it python3 just as the default and I
want to make sure I'm using this inside
or outside of something like a virtual
environment to render my document out
and again IPython will execute the
python code and transform that output to
plain text graphics and markdown that is
then embedded inside the document and
rendered out to the final output with
quarto so IPython or the jupyter kernels
handling all the computation quarters
structuring the document and then
compiling it all together at the very
end but importantly you get to use the
tools you kind of expect or the
workflows you'd expect with tools like
IPython and Jupiter kernels
for interactive sessions and again put
those things like previews quarter
actually keeps the the Jupiter kernel
resident alive as a background Daemon to
mitigate some of the startup times and
make it really efficient in its
computation as well so you can not have
to restart and redo everything every
time you can actually keep a stateful
kernel around as you're working
another thing that Cordo provides and in
that Jupiter notebooks provide is this
idea of reproducibility or stored or
frozen computation so Jupiter notebooks
natively allow for this you can actually
store The Source Code the output file
and cached output in a single document
and that's what a Jupiter notebook is
behind the scenes it's Json and it's
actually storing all of that state along
with the source code in a single
document
in some cases that's amazing and in
other cases people want to actually
split those out and we'll talk a little
bit about that
there's also Jupiter cache which allows
you to provide transient caching of cell
outputs for an entire Dock and in this
case if any of the cells in the dock are
changed then all the cells will be
re-executed which is a little bit
different than how a traditional Jupiter
notebook works
and then quarto has a different kind of
approach to this but Builds on some of
the ideas so Cordo uses what's called
Freeze and this uses a multi-file
approach you have source code as your
input and it's going to again be a plain
text quarter markdown event or a Jupiter
notebook
you have a complete output file that's
separate so you're creating like an HTML
page or PDF document or PowerPoint
presentation and then you're also
storing the computation separately by
its exact directory and file as Json so
this allows you to permanently save and
reuse computational outputs across an
entire project across multiple files and
even multiple languages you're not just
stuck with a single document or even a
single cell you can actually save out
and extract out the computation
separately from each of the other
components
and they can always again work with
Jupiter notebooks you're not having to
give up that option but it builds on it
for reproducibility reasons
I keep on saying this idea that a
quarter markdown document is a plain
text file and I want to re-emphasize
what that looks like and then compare it
to some of the options that we have
again a quarter markdown document is
plain text it's mainly formed from the
metadata or the yaml header at the very
top this again allows you to define a
format like HTML or PDF choose an engine
in this case I'm using a Jupiter kernel
named python3 but if I'm using it with r
i could also say use an engine of
Knitter to natively execute it in r
instead of python
I could write uh code chunks so in
Python it would look like this three
back ticks fence brackets with python as
the language and then I do you know from
a language or from a library import a
bunch of things and then do a quick
Group by summarize
and then text or markdown is consistent
across both languages so I'm not doing
it one way in r or one way in python or
one way in Julia I'm doing the exact
same markdown structure and overall
structure in my document consistently
with this enhanced scientific markdown
so Bolding headers hyperlinks even
structuring the document itself is done
with markdown robustly across formats
and languages
but Cordo doesn't have to be plain text
and if you want to use a Jupiter
notebook as your primary interface Cordo
can absolutely do that
if you want to make a chordophy Jupiter
notebook you can actually just include a
raw chunk at the top Define some of your
yaml front matter there so again like a
title a format which language engine you
want to use for it and then you just
work as usual or as normal in your
jupyter notebook
on the right we have the quarto preview
which is showing that real-time
rendering of the document as you're
making changes so you can still do your
inline computation but also see the
final output as you're working so you
have the option of doing both
so that rendering pipeline is you get to
choose your own adventure you can have a
plain text workflow where a quarter
markdown document uses a Jupiter kernel
writes out of intermediary markdown file
which is read by pandok and converted
into the final format
but you also have a notebook workflow
where you can reuse the stored
computation in that jupyter notebook or
optionally re-execute the whole document
top to bottom to make sure that it's
done linearly and not out of order and
in this case we don't actually even have
a quarter markdown document in the
workflow we're just using a normal
jupyter notebook an IPython notebook
and so this makes it really easy to
answer the question well what do I do
with my existing IPython notebooks you
keep using them you don't have to stop
using them if you love Jupiter keep
using them and you can enhance them or
do other things alongside with quarto so
you get to choose whether to use that
stored computation or again re-execute
the document from top to bottom
so with code it might look something
like Porto render my favorite jupyter
notebook to HTML and I want to
re-execute it so I want to make sure
that I didn't accidentally execute the
last cell before the first cell and now
it won't work I want to make sure it's
truly reproducible
although if I know it's already good to
go or someone hands off one I can still
render with quarto and again reuse that
existing computation that's stored
within it
quarto can also convert back and forth
between the plain text qmd and a Jupiter
notebook representation this is not
rendering but actually just changing the
structuring of the source code so I can
go from qmd to IPython notebook an
IPython notebook back to qmd so if
you're doing a collaboration where one
person likes jupyter notebooks one
person likes plain text or dot Pi files
you can convert back and forth this is
kind of similar to how jupitax
approaches it but of course like Porto
has a a bigger kind of dream than just
kind of the plain text format we're
doing a lot with both Jupiter notebooks
and also with just plain text qmds
themselves
I also want to really hit on this idea
of that uh Jupiter notebooks are amazing
and quarto is trying to kind of work
with that ecosystem and help out and
assist with different things so if
you're familiar with Jeremy Howard from
fast.ai or hamal Hussein who's also part
of the fasted AI team they recently did
some reworking of nbdev which is a way
of using Jupiter notebooks to write
python packages and do a whole lot of
other things and they enhanced it by
using quarto on top of the existing
Jupiter notebooks they're working with
they have a lovely uh blog post that you
could do an entire presentation on
called mbdev plus quarto a new secret
weapon for productivity but ultimately
they go through this idea of using
jupyter notebooks here at the core using
Cordo to build out some of the websites
and documentation that they're working
on and then using their typical workflow
of Jupiter Pipi GitHub and other tooling
to actually do their development in
Python but bringing quarto into the
equation where it makes sense and that's
where it's optional to opt in and it's
really exciting to me that we're
building on as opposed to trying to uh
kind of be at odds with other
communities
what this really means is that you get
to choose and be comfortable in your own
workspace of course you can keep using
your Jupiter notebook and you can use
Jupiter lab or the classic Jupiter
notebook to write your documents you can
write an IPython notebook and then just
render it with Porto
for other people who would prefer to use
text editors as opposed to a notebook
interface we also wrote a vs code
extension so inside vs code you actually
have the ability to use a plain text qmd
you get this kind of notebook Style run
cell option and we can also attach an
interactive IPython console directly to
that qmd side by side so you can
interactively do your Computing but also
keep your source code as plain text
so a lot of power here to kind of work
with different popular text editors as
well as Jupiter notebook and then of
course you know posit has this love and
continuation of R in our studio you can
use quarto markdown documents they're
baked in very deeply to our studio so if
you ever do R and python together or you
are an R programmer
um you know our studio has amazing
support for quarter markdown documents
I also want to call out that vs code
with that quarter extension along with
our studio have really rich intellisense
or Auto completion so for the yaml it
can be kind of confusing sometimes when
you're just getting started to remember
all the different options
so we actually have Auto completion in
vs code in our studio for the yaml
header so all the different options you
can choose
as well as for code chunks they also
have Auto completion for the different
code chunk options in addition to the
native like python intellisense that you
have in vs code and this is very similar
to what we do in our studio with things
like R and python as well as the yaml
and the chunk option so it's available
in both
now Switching gears a little bit as we
kind of get into the later half of the
presentation there was also this idea of
single Source publishing so to show this
off I love Boston Terriers I've got a
little Boston Terrier at home I want to
write this article about them and I
borrowed some information from Wikipedia
I'm creating a beautiful HTML website
but then I also need to create a PDF
because someone wants to receive that
with the exact same source code without
writing any CSS or any latex I can write
a document one time and convert to both
HTML into PDF
that HTML document looks like this
really nice I've got a lot of different
structuring I've got a JavaScript
enabled hover text for citations I've
got a floating table of contents I've
got images in in the gutter bar lots of
customization all done with Cordo
natively with markdown
and then when I render to PDF I get a
very similar looking document with PDF
but obviously constrained to what PDF
can do I still have those citations but
now they're footnotes rather than hover
text and I still have the structuring
overall the document with the image in
the gutter bar there
so again you can imagine writing a
journal article but also publishing it
as a beautiful website so you can do a
lot with Porto
and this idea of unified syntax across
both markdown and code also applies for
just structuring the document
so here on the left we have an example
of just taking two images from disk and
laying them out left and right in there
this will work inside presentations
documents every different structure we
can just say layout number of columns
equals two
but we can also do this on the fly with
Graphics we're creating with python and
now I'm using python code to generate
two images and then align them again
with this layout number of column equals
two and giving them their own little
figure captions of scatter and box plot
so you can imagine that you're learning
at one time and then it applies across
all the different formats all these
different languages and even across
different code chunks and the markdown
itself for consistency's purpose
so this idea of built into quarto versus
having to rebuild it all on your own or
custom is that we're trying to provide a
markdown Centric format agnostic syntax
as shown in these previous slides so
quarto bundles all sorts of things to
make this even better like we've built
in bootstrap CSS and themes we respect
SAS variables for styling HTML we
include latex templates for specific
journals as well as good defaults or
PDFs in general we respect docx and
PowerPoint templates again allowing for
robust styling for more kind of office
Centric things
so really you shouldn't have to escape
out to writing raw latex HTML Ginger
templates or anything else in the vast
majority of situations you can rely
purely on this enhanced markdown syntax
that we're providing which provides
consistency
but of course if you're building content
for a single output and you're knowing I
only want to create HTML then yeah you
can include as much HTML and CSS and
JavaScript as you want to optimize for
that format
and in the spirit of that you can
actually extend quarto with what are
called extensions you can add your own
custom short codes for things like font
awesome icons and you can embed those
and change the little short codes you
have into images
you can create your own filters to
stylize code chunks so that it shows the
file name of the code you're bringing in
and then displays your matplot lib code
or you can Define your own entirely new
custom formats and like the presentation
I use today you could have this be a
theme that you're using for your own
company style presentation or your own
organization that you're working with
now the last thing I want to talk about
and then we'll wrap it up is that quarto
also bundles this idea of interactivity
of course as you'd expect Jupiter
widgets all work with quarto so I have
interaction in my slides and I can
actually like select different things
and work directly with these uh images
in Cordo as well as in jupyter notebooks
but Cordo also bundles of uh some work
with JavaScript in a specifically
observable JavaScript which is an
enhancement to vanilla JavaScript by
Mike Bostock and team who is the author
of D3
and this gives us the ability to embed
these type of things which are written
purely with JavaScript and I actually
don't have to use r or python to
generate these I could actually enhance
them and add in JavaScript specific
Graphics directly into all of my HTML
style outputs
now Graphics are great like this but
ultimately I might also want to add
little widgets on the Fly I don't want
to write a whole new Jupiter widget or
IPython widget I can actually create
little widgets like this purely with
observable and say well I'm in the US
some of you all are Global in other
countries where you use proper degrees
Celsius as opposed to Fahrenheit
it's about 60 degrees here in Texas
which is about 16 degrees Celsius so I
had this nice little conversion tool
baked into my presentation
and writing these is really simple
because you just have an OJs chunk or
observable JavaScript chunk and then you
can add in all the components as needed
the very last thing is like okay you try
all these things out you're really
excited and you want to show it off to
the world where can you publish it so
quarto publish in the court of CLI
actually allows you to publish to a lot
of places GitHub Pages posit connect
netlify or our free tool called quarto
Pub so you can sign up there and then
publish all of your documents in python
or other languages and host them there
so other people can see them and you can
share them with your colleagues
okay
with that I'm going to wrap up and
hopefully have about a minute left for
questions first off Cordo is crafted
with love and care by posit PBC the same
core Team Works on both Cordo and
maintains our markdown but Cordo is open
source and we have a full contributor
list you're welcome to add on issues or
suggest features or even do pull
requests to add different things and you
can find that at quarterdev quarto CLI
on GitHub
I'll leave this page up as kind of the
overview what we talked about you can
always find these slides at Thomas
mock.cordo.pub Python and if you just
want to try out and get started with
quarto and python this link at the
bottom actually allows you to get
started with vs code our studio Jupiter
or even a random text editor
um with that I'll take questions
um and thank you Steve for having me
no problem thank you so much let's try
to tackle this one we've got a couple
moments
yeah absolutely great question from Ron
so this intermediary between quarto and
shiny so you can imagine that quarto is
actually going to provide a dashboard
style layout so you can actually embed
shiny for python directly into quarto
documents today and in the future we'll
have more of a dashboard style layout
that you can use
also shining for python allows for
what's called shiny live which is a wasm
based implementation of uh applications
meaning you could run it entirely
client-side with things like um
trying to think of what the pi script
and things like that where you're
running it purely in the browser as
opposed to needing a server back end so
yes we have that on the uh on the
workflow